[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont venus à fort-de-france petit
balcon temple de la musique
traditionnelle compositeurs musiciens
artistes femmes
il était là peut accueillir saluer et
partager des moments d'émotion avec
charles aznavour
des ambassadeurs de la chanson française
l'artiste international avec une grande
simplicité à visiter le musée
s'intéressant à l'art la culture et au
patrimoine
puis marie ange ravin et l' orchestre la
vieille garde ont accueilli le chantre
de la chanson française entouré de
représentants de la sacem mon rythme
poésie expression du coeur se sont
relayés pour le bonheur de tous charles
aznavour avec son talent légendaire a
démontré que travail amitié respect
partage et convivialité se conjugue au
delà des frontières
c'est à ce moment travail accompli
l'artiste peut dire j'ai vécu ou encore
on a toujours 20 ans
[Musique]
nous avons passé un moment et si
exceptionnel avec charles aznavour
il a joué avec barel coppet tu il a
félicité barel coppet peau sont son
roman sa sacralité de deux musiciens et
lâches ou et il a joué pour la première
fois je pense un public lui même il a
joué du piano sur le piano viella il a
joué
donc et il a chanté et c'était vraiment
une soirée exceptionnelle
toutes les personnes qui étaient là et
et enchanté par la venue d'un nouveau
parmi eux